Це одна з найбільш завантажених частин
автобану А9 поблизу Мюнхена.
Ось так тут ремонтували ділянку довжиною 4 кілометри.
Щоб уникнути транспортного колапсу,
довелося працювати у надзвичайно стислі терміни.
Всю роботу виконали за 48 годин.
Добу працювали на одних вихідних
і потім ще добу на наступних.
Реконструкція цієї ділянки коштувала майже 5 мільйонів євро.
Щоправда, не всі дороги у Німеччині ремонтують аж так швидко.
Деякі роботи розтягуються на місяці,
але в підсумку все зроблять якісно.
Німецькі дороги, передусім, автобани - візитівка країни.
Їх майже 13 тисяч кілометрів і це одна з найбільших мереж у світі.
Крім того, є ще 40 тисяч кілометрів федеральних доріг
та сотні тисяч місцевого значення.
Ямковий ремонт у Німеччині роблять рідко.
Звісно, є місця, де можна зустріти латки на дорогах,
але це здебільшого винятки, які підтверджують правило:
старий асфальт краще взагалі зрізати і покласти новий.
Замість старого покриття настилають новий
шар асфальту завтовшки 8-10 сантиметрів.
Потім ще один шар в середньому 4 сантиметри.
Товщина обох шарів може бути й більшою залежно від того,
де прокладено дорогу і наскільки інтенсивно її будуть експлуатувати.
Коли йдеться вже не про ремонт, а будівництво з "нуля",
то спершу дуже детально досліджують ґрунт
і проводять дренажні роботи.
Дороги у Німеччині, передусім автобани,
будують за принципом "бутерброда".
Спершу настилають кілька несучих шарів
на бітумній основі завтовшки не менше півметра.
Потім верхній шар з високоякісних гірських порід -
це ще кілька сантиметрів.
І лише після цього така "подушка" покривається
асфальтом з шорсткою поверхнею, яка забезпечує
відмінне зчеплення шин з дорогою і запобігає
підвищенню допустимого рівня шуму.